hello everyone i would like to preface
this interview by saying something very
important
that i know is a fundamental upstream
solution
which will solve many of our downstream
issues
many of us are wondering how can we
optimize civilization's
sense making what kind of communications
architectures are optimal to catalyze
love wisdom harmony and sustainable
growth the answer
that you'll find in this episode is
simply
emotionally intelligent conversation
by giving david the space to express his
world view we together came up with
excellent solutions for sense-making on
the topic
there was no name-calling there was no
yelling
there was no anger there was no ego
there was just genuine authentic sincere
inquiry into perspective
you'll find us uncover and strategize on
two solutions to how we can make sense
on this topic as a civilization i will
go ahead and explain them here because
they fascinate me
and can help us harmonize as a society
flat earth cartography has antarctica
as an outer ring surrounding the
continents
there have been efforts from independent
teams to explore this but they
have not come to fruition
in creating two business models around
antarctica tourism
we can quickly provide all humans that
are
interested with the front row seat to
experiential
knowledge of the truth of our home
number one flights over antarctica
from south america to australia from
south africa to new zealand
how fun would it be to have david weiss
on a plane with neil degrasse tyson
and an unbiased film crew number two
ships cruise around antarctica with
the shoreline in sight
cruise around it yourself or
have a loved one and you take two boats
to cruise around it and meet
there are already some projects which
are actualizing these goals
there are always empathetic wise
loving scientific experiential
upstream solutions it is
up to us to be intelligent enough to
identify these
and implement them this
sense making synchronicity was recorded
on the winter solstice
all life is beautiful art
develop the faculties to see it
enjoy the episode
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
i'm your host
atlas super excited to be talking about
all things flat earth we have david
weiss joining us hi david
hey man thanks for having me excited for
the discussion
likewise very excited and you have a lot
of great visuals that you'll be sharing
with us
as well which i'm really looking forward
to unpacking with you
all right yeah and as you know our show
is
very deeply rooted in metaphysics and
consciousness the nature of reality
so i'd like to start things off by
asking you about that and then we'll
get into some of the flat earth stuff so
what do you think
the nature of existence is all about why
does reality exist
that's such a big question man um you
know
the whole the whole metaphysical look at
reality and simulation theory
makes so much more sense on a flat earth
it works
on a flat earth it doesn't work on a
spinning rock ball
you know space rocket world um that
happened by
random you know random explosion so
why does it exist i believe it exists
for our soul's journey i believe we are
here
in our avatars having a soul's journey
and that our number one
rule the number one mission is to
maintain control of our soul
and not sell it and so we're here to
expand
consciousness and
you know those people that get lost
that get fooled into giving up their
souls in the
soul lure system they get
fished away um they have really hard
lives they
they get become unhealthy they become
lost they become depressed
remember the scene at the beginning of
the matrix the documentary with
keanu reeves right where he uh
hello if i caught a documentary
he um at the beginning he was like
depressed he's like something's wrong
something's wrong
there's something out there and he
didn't know what he was looking for
i i truly believe that um the
the globe lie i call it is the reason
that many people are depressed because
their inner core their soul
knows the truth they're deep down inside
the truth is there
but they can't see it so they're not
aligning with their soul
and they become depressed and and all
different things happen when you're
depressed you go off the off the path
so you know
i've seen people discover the flat earth
and everything everything changed for me
i've seen people become happier i see
people in really tough life situations
that are so happy they're so happy
you know because you know that it's not
about the material world the material
world
and don't get me wrong i love my
material everyone loves a little good
little material you know
it's comfort comforting you know those
headphones
are nice it's a material um
but people uh people
get lost in that and uh when you
understand who you are where you are and
what you are
more so than on a spinning ball you're
um
i have a lot better foundation and
you're a lot happier
how's that for an answer yeah there
there definitely
seems to be a perennial wisdom around
the unity of all being in existence
whether we talk about it like a god
or a source and that we
undergo the process as that we are that
and then we do this exploration of
phenomenology an exploration of all
these different
states of consciousness that possibly
exist
and that this reality is one
design this is one creation design and
then we
immerse ourselves in these sole vehicles
so this is another this is just one
design of a sole vehicle
and then we undergo this explorative
process and that we've infinitely and
eternally been doing this and we will
continue doing it
because you can never come to an end of
exploring
infinite states of consciousness
infinite phenomenological possibility
so that seems to be what is one of the
prominent metaphysical ways of thinking
right now
and another aspect to it that i thought
was interesting was that
whether it be a flat earth or
whether it be any sort of way
of living that is sort of outside of the
quote
matrix as you talked about i just think
that
that generally is an uplifting way
of living life which is basically i'm
going to
say enough of the economic
machinery that is in many ways
de-sacralizing life and
it i i want to feel like
i'm a divine being i don't want to work
40 hours every week from 9 to 5
doing something that i don't love and so
we need to sort of work our way over
time into a civilizational architecture
that is more around the you the
unleashing
of the unique gift of every single soul
in a way that is aligned with their
highest potential and their highest
actualization and so that's something
else that we're very
adamant about um talking about on the
show so whatever whatever it is in terms
of that
sort of thinking it's all outside of the
matrix is kind of the point
for me there yeah so you know when you
look at
um what we're doing here why we're here
there's something
and and it's maybe it's just the duality
of it
where there's a evil for i'll use the
word evil
that is trying to lure our souls away
they use the soul lure system as i said
and
um maybe that's necessary
for the contrast it is yeah i'm with you
and and and and i believe uh
wholeheartedly that
we chose to be here during this time to
have this ride
2020 has been an amazing year for me
because two things that i really love
roller coasters
and puzzles yeah there you go that's
this yeah that's this well
i'm like this is the greatest thing ever
i mean the world's falling apart there's
people that have no idea what's coming
down the pike here
and they're they're they're basically
just lost but
it's fascinating to watch and and
because i'm aware
of this journey that we're on i see the
bigger picture
at least that's the way i see it and uh
um
you know there's no fear or anything you
know when i since i discovered flat
earth i've lost
all fear of everything because most of
the big fears you know
they have that than the mainstream media
pushes out from you know nuclear bombs
and asteroids and
you know those are fake both of those
are fake i don't know if you're aware of
that
nuclear bombs don't exist and neither do
asteroids this is these are on my
list to talk to you about let's let's
let's um let's hit this also
from a little bit of a chronological
perspective and we'll keep revisiting
this on a it's all going to be very
metaphysical and consciousness driven as
well
but so in terms of a chronology to this
process
walk us through what were those kind of
pivotal moments for you
that unlocked this sort of way of
thinking
as you were growing up so
well growing up i always questioned
everything and
i was in uh kindergarten first grade or
whatever and
during uh they brought us outside we
always you know i was so excited to go
outside
you know and the teacher was teaching us
about gravity
and uh this is like first grade i think
it was kindergarten
you know and uh the teacher had a bucket
of water
on a rope and he swung the water around
and he said this is great he got to go
and spin around and now he's going
full circles and the water's going in
there he goes that's gravity
okay and i said to the teacher i go i
when he was done i said
but if we're on a ball and the water's
on the ball and it's spinning
don't you have to turn the bucket around
the other way right
so the water's on the outside and not on
the inside
and the teacher goes like this he goes
he's got a big beard he goes
he goes
a good question he goes he goes
that's the way i was told to teach it
that's why i have to teach it but you
keep asking questions
that's what he told me and i remember
that it was like my earliest memory of
school
so that kind of started me off going all
right he's teaching it because that's
how he has to teach it even though it
makes no sense so
i always that was disillusioned that
school from that point on with school
jumping all the way forward you know
through the
through my adult life i just saw so much
deception in the world and
what really got me into it was i don't
know about 20 years ago
i said what the heck is money what is
money and i started looking into money
yeah fiat is another huge way into
yeah and but the whole decentralization
and cryptocurrency revolution is
fantastic that's right that's amazing
i'm big on crypto yeah the creature of
jekyll island yeah yeah yeah yeah the
whole thing and so
so um just in a nutshell real quick you
know
i worked in corporate america and we
my buddy and i we were we would always
be like talking about stuff in the
lunchroom and people gather around it
turned out
to the point like when i walked in the
lunchroom like yeah they're here there
there's a whole group of people
and we're talking about you know federal
reserve other deceptions
then i ended up doing a podcast called
deep inside the rabbit hole
where we dove into all of the big
deceptions of the world
and then in the third year people
started sending me flat earth stuff like
hey have you looked into flat earth i'm
like
get out of here and i ban people from
our social media for even
for suggesting such a thing just being
so stupid leave me alone
i'm not gonna watch your stupid video
and then i was forced to by a researcher
that i trust very much
um i said to her i said there's so much
deception in the world
it's mind-blowing a little literally
where there was some you know
fake plane crashed for something that
happened and she goes oh david it's
worse than that
i think the earth might be flat and i'm
like
get out of town so then i just said all
right that's it i'm going to prove the
globe i'm not going to debunk flat earth
flat earth is stupid i'm going to prove
the globe which will debunk flat earth
and then uh two weeks later i came out
the other side
and i'm like oh boy well there's a
problem and here i am
i i've left my own i had my own company
i left my company
i'm doing this full-time now it's
insanity
it's it's amazing and spiritually
energetically life is so amazing right
now
you know in the end people go what
difference does the shape of the earth
make
i still have to go to work tomorrow you
know what difference does it make well
it's not the shape that matters it's the
lie that matters
it's about hiding the spiritual journey
that you're on they don't want you to
know
that your thoughts create your reality
they don't want you to know
that they have no power over you they
can't make you do
anything you just believe it and then
it's true if you believe it
how's that yeah
i'm looking forward to unpacking all
these core concepts more yeah there's a
lot of importance to
the understanding of consciousness
creates
reality and the idea of future
authoring is something that's deep in
the psychology
psychological literature and it's also
deep in the self-help literature
and the self-actualization literature
it's super important it has a deep
amount of
synthesis to do with physicalism
especially given
what we're trying to understand about
quantum mechanics and our relationship
with that
so super fascinating and then now
let's let's unpack some of these core
concepts because uh you started us
off with gravity gravity seems to be one
that is a core
concept here so normally what we think
is we think that the earth is spherical
that all of the normal sort of concepts
around the solar system itself
and also the fact that the gravitational
pull from the core
of the earth is what is
the process of what's creating that sort
of
that style of space-time fabric as
einstein would say and that sort of
curvature
that is created from the earth and then
that sort of
that sort of heaviness at the center of
the core that's pulling things down so
yeah so walk us through what your
thoughts are about gravity then
yeah so all of that is pseudoscience
it's amazing
and when once you see it you're like wow
how did i ever believe that and the
thing is we're trusting
human beings and that we'd like to trust
people especially
people that are in places of authority
teachers and
you know whatever so gravity
according to mainstream science
according to the high priest of the
mainstream science neil degrasse tyson
is just a theory
they don't know what it is every
experiment they tried to do that with
mass attracting mass
has failed it hasn't done anything as a
matter of fact the whole solar system
the gra the amount of gravity doesn't
work so they have to add
dark matter into it okay dark matter's
never been seen
it's never been tested but it has to
exist because gravity doesn't work
without dark matter
so that's equivalent of saying hey hey
um atlas i owe you a hundred bucks
here's four dollars and then i'm going
to venmo you
96 dark dollars you can't see them
but they're there you have to trust me
yeah that's the percentage approximately
is yeah
and it still doesn't work including dark
energy yeah dark energy and dark
matter yeah you're both yeah yeah so so
there's something there's energy there's
ether you know and that's why they
introduced einstein to get rid of the
ether and bring in his
his the relativity stuff um but um
that nasa has a thing called the three
body problem okay
and what that is is they can create a um
a super computer model they got a ball
and that ball um has a certain amount of
gravity
and then they can create another ball
the earth you know
and set it in orbit and it works
beautifully it works perfect okay
and it'll go for years and years and
years and
being predictable and they know exactly
what it's going to be then you add a
third body
another planet moon whenever of any size
and put it in orbit around one of those
beings one of those things and the
entire thing falls apart
it goes random it never repeats itself
and it's over
that's with three bodies our solar
system has like 80 bodies in it
with all the moons they keep changing it
right it would be like a beehive
that you kicked okay but if you go out
tonight and look at the stars at 10
o'clock or anytime
and mark where the stars are next year
this time 10 years from now at the same
time on the same night
those stars will be in the exact same
position
the sky clock is a perfect clock it has
gears
just like you know you know fine watch
um the wheels in the sky keep on turning
so think about this
the the earth is falling around the sun
that's that's what it's doing you know
the sun's pulling it but it's moving
sideways so fast that it keeps missing
the sun and
orbiting that's what an orbit supposedly
is
the moon is falling around the earth
what happens when the moon gets in
between the sun and the earth how come
the sun's gravity doesn't pull it away
okay or at least tug it just a little
bit
how about when all the planets align
like right now jupiter and saturn
are on top of each other but no
nothing's getting pulled out of its
orbit
it's because gravity is a mess so real
quick i'll just tell you what gravity is
on the flat earth
the earth is and the only true forces
that we know of
are electricity and magnetism and their
brother and sister they go together
the earth is a dielectric plane and it
has a measurable
negative charge to it measurable and
that negative charge
establishes a down it says okay i'm
going to pull this piece of dust
down this piece of metal whatever it is
attracts it's a very weak force just
like they say gravity is a weak
force but it could hold oceans and
cruise ships upside down in australia
it establishes a down and then buoyancy
and density sort everything else out
we can do dozens of experiments with
electromagnets electricity
where and magnetism where we can defy
defy gravity or defy electromagnetism
we're defying electromagnetism we could
take you and see those little triangle
tin foil things that people make and
they electrify them and they float the
air
right electricity and magnetism
so that's what gravity is and
the only true direction is down
you know down and up you know left and
right don't matter because if i turn
around
left changes directions forward and
backwards don't matter because if i turn
around like backwards is now forwards
but up and down are always up and down
and they're not
not up isn't in australia one way
and in north america another way you
know up is up and down is down
typically that graphic behind you the
way that
we've understood it is that there's uh
astrodynamics that are occurring between
the celestial bodies that enable them to
stay
in such positions and that over a period
of
what we hypothesize as sever several
billion years of evolution
that life evolved on our rock on our
earth and that gave us the ability
and that's why we think that the solar
system is so sacred in a sense because
it has this like unique
celestial body composition that enables
it to be
stable enough for a planet in the
habitable
zone to evolve sentience that then can
reflect on the nature of its existence
so a lot of this information comes from
nasa
all right you with me so let's let's
just for a couple minutes because we can
do a whole show on this
just deconstruct nasa because i'm gonna
show you that nasa
are liars and therefore you're gonna
have to discount
anything that you ever hear from nasa
every single thing
so um what
planet is this this is jupiter right
so in 2016 nasa goes look we got this
picture of the
northern lights on on jupiter that's
amazing
right and of course we said that's fake
okay but how do we prove it's fake well
we really can't prove it's fake because
it could be real
if that if there were northern lights
there maybe they do look like that maybe
that's a time-lapse picture
but we're told that jupiter is made of
gases and storms and
these rings are these bands are actually
spinning in opposite directions
these things and this storm right here
is
you know spinning and spinning and these
are turbulence coming off the storm well
these pictures were taken two years
apart if you overlay them over each
other they're exactly the same
every single dot is exactly the same
like this little dot right here
it's right here it's right there
everything's the same
that proves to you that nasa's lying
when they show us
stuff like this did you see ever seen
the recent picture of pluto the planet
yeah we had some of the leads on that
project on the on the show yeah
yeah so this is that's kind of that's
kind of cute that's kind of funny
that shit's hilarious
also for those that don't know david has
said that nasa and disney are the same
company
they work together they're both
hollywood you know studios okay okay
i don't know who's getting this is
funniest i might be ruffling some
feathers but
i'm just showing you information you got
to make up your own mind
but because i think it was the cassini
spacecraft it could be a different one
it's flying by it like oh that's sorry
that's the new horizons the one that
went
to yeah pluto yeah yeah so new horizons
is the one all right thank you for
connecting with me
cassini so it doesn't matter cassini is
cassini's saturn and then new horizons
is pluto yeah new horizons thank you
but it's flying by 60 000 miles an hour
from the distance pluto is from the sun
the sun is like almost like a star
so how is pluto that bright how did they
get a perfect
full pluto you know like a full moon
full pluto picture and send it back to
earth i mean
let's just assume they have amazing
wi-fi up there but
it's just it's got pluto the dog on it
not enough to say
that's definitely pluto but it's
ridiculous and pluto the dog
was created the same year that pluto the
planet was
um was made people say well what about
what about photos of earth here are two
photos of earth
from nasa okay this look at the size of
the united states here
and this one the united states is rolled
backwards a little bit so it should be
smaller but it's twice the size
okay i know they're at a different angle
but this one
like if i if i took this one and rolled
it back it gets smaller it doesn't get
bigger
okay this one's bigger and it's
rolled back this is fake nasa admits
it's fake
their their artists um what's his name
uh
whatever his name is based on his name
but the guy that created uh
uh robert simmons he created the blue
marble picture that's on everyone's
iphone when it first came out
and if you look these clouds are stepped
and repeated he admits
in an interview that he made it from
data in photoshop
and people will still argue that this is
a photo of earth
and he says he admits that it's not but
there are no photos of earth
right and let me ask you a question if
you went to the moon
you were the first guy on the moon and
you brought a golf cart
and golf clubs and you dune buggied
around the moon
you played golf and you successfully
made it back to earth
and you had a press conference would you
look like that
would you would you be that excited
these guys look like their dog was just
shot
okay this is the press conference when
they got back from the moon and the only
excuse the nasa fanboys have is they
were tired
they just got back from the moon where
they played golf
and wrote a dune buggy and talked to
president nixon
on the telephone with no delay
okay you know president nixon talked to
them
from the white house and there was no
delay
on the call and meanwhile you know felix
baumgarten
when he did his red bull jump at a 127
000 feet they could barely communicate
with him
in 2005 versus 1967 where they can talk
to the moon i can go on
all day i could show you a video after
video after video of
nasa faking being in space
but you only need one of these things
that i that i've showed you um to know
that they're that they're lying and then
once you realize that they're lying
you have to unwind unwind that um
and and realize what it means
so i'm very curious about
what the idea of
space then means because
there appears to be so much that's
occurring
in in in space in terms of
you know you have that hoax shirt on and
that
we have a supposed international space
station
that is somewhere around um 250 or so
miles
up that is orbiting the earth every
approximately
um 90 or so
minutes and so there's a
uh a crew of people that are supposedly
there
that are undergoing scientific uh
research
there's also supposedly a tremendous
amount of satellites that exist
in orbit um low earth orbit um
all of the different orbits that provide
us with a lot of the
a lot of the communicational
infrastructures
that we need as a planet in order to be
able to talk to each other
or uh the or for gps
purposes so then if
you know if we're not sending up
satellites via rockets
that are then staying in orbit around a
sphere
um or you know or even in this case with
the
with the international space station
over there or what the rocket companies
around the planet are doing
you know what are those you know rocket
companies doing what
how do we have satellites that enable us
to communicate or
or what is your perspective on those
things then
so that's that's a lot to unpack there
so we don't believe that satellites
exist
we know that nasa is the largest
consumer of helium in the world
and they have many balloon programs
um and they put up you know eight
thousand pound satellites on these
balloons
that orbit the earth that float over the
earth and they can control them by their
by remotely controlling their height
into different wind currents
and they can keep them um wherever they
need to so there's tens of thousands of
these things up there they crashed all
over the earth and they're quickly
retrieved
um we've talked to military guys that uh
that had that talk about how they
recover these balloons in midair before
they crash
so why doesn't nasa tell us about these
balloon programs
i mean we fund them they give them 65
million dollars
every single day of the year okay
and it goes up every year 65 million
dollars a day what have they done
they've lied to us um so
you know that's what satellites are gps
ground positioning system um only works
when you're near land when you fly to
hawaii from california
you go into approximated mode as soon as
you're 100 200 miles offshore
then no longer sees the plane it just
calculates where you are
when you fly over the amazon jungle
there is no gps
when you fly over the southern oceans
there's no gps
okay so um the iss
i was trying to i have a video but i
don't like i guess i didn't upload it
um where we have not one not two not ten
but thousands of
um videos of them faking floating on the
iss
faking moving things around when they're
flipping their mics around
and playing with water balls that's done
in uh
with pure cgi with uh with um
you know some of its cgi sometimes they
do it in a zero g plane when they have
recorded stuff
but they're playing with virtual reality
they're we have an image where
they actually went to pass a hat and he
missed it
and he moved he thought he had it but it
didn't go
we have them when they do their flips
their wires get tangled their feet get
caught in the wires one time a guy
grabbed the wire
and pulled it the other times the the
their layering effect screwed up and we
could see their harnesses
right you have to catch them once faking
being on the iss to know there's a
problem
green screen glitches where they totally
you know glitz out
um all sorts of stuff you know
and then now with their fake rocket
landings look at these this is
a movie from the 1950s and this is
supposedly happening now
okay that that it's going to show again
this rocket here there's 10 foot waves
out there you couldn't stand on that
boat
this thing is 40 tons empty
coming out of the sky and that little
bit of fire is going to land it right on
that raft and
20 knots of wind okay this is a fantasy
none of this stuff is real it's
it goes on and on and on but you only
need
one thing to prove that these guys are
lying
and now you may have guests on your show
um
they don't know that they're lying they
are satellite technicians
they are um control room people in the
control room
one of the guys you know in the in the
nasa control room says
we do so many simulations that are so
realistic
that we can't tell the difference
between a simulation
and the real mission because it's kind
of like what reality is
in many ways but you can't really tell
the difference that's why this
already is that it's so interesting here
this will this will melt your brain
this is the 2012 shot of the
you know from space of course they got a
full earth like a full moon
and you can see the united states right
here well i've represented
the on the map here of all the lands of
earth
what we're seeing on this half of the
ball you have to believe
that all of this land all of the rest of
it
is on the other side of that ball
somebody didn't get their proportions
right all of this land
is on the other side of this ball
that's not right this is a painting
they're lying to you about
space so what is space
right what is space
you want to know uh
yeah well let's uh let's let's ask one
question right before we get to this
which
is that now one of the big
sort of ways of also viewing
these topics is to as we take it from a
very
macro level view is that we sort of
aim to understand well when you when you
ask the simple question about
what is money right even that question
is so profoundly important to ask
ourselves and especially as children
growing up in the world
and how can we have an exchange of value
that is more abundant and more around
our flourishing
and less around something that can be so
easily corrupted and have these perverse
incentives like we're experiencing today
and so you kind of begin to wonder well
you know how many people
know about the perverse incentives
around the fiat currencies and how many
of them are involved in
in that process and then you can maybe
ask a similar question about
what happened on september 11 2001
and you can ask a similar question
wonder
you know what actually happened then and
what may be some of the perverse
incentives that are involved in order
to create financial or lucrative
uh abundance for a certain small class
of people involved there
and what that sort of triggered
geopolitically
afterward after that event and then
finally sort of the way to tie it in is
like with what you're talking about
regarding
flat earth and space is something
similar would have to be happening
where you would basically have a a small
percentage of people in this case i'm
just looking at some of the
numbers it looks like there's about 17
000 people that are employed at
nasa and there's about eight there's
about eight thousand hold on
hold on who reports the number that you
just got
nasa gave you that number yeah there
well that's just that's just the number
from
from specifically from nasa but we've
also i just want to also say that we've
interviewed
i don't know maybe a couple dozen people
that are involved in the astrophysics
industries across these different
organizations
and that's a very small amount of the
total amount of people that
actually are employed there and then i
just want to say the spacex number is
about 8 000 employees
and then you have to extrapolate even
more because there's the european space
agency
there's a lot of space agencies around
the world that have thousands of
employees
so just basically my point would be that
there would in a sense have to be
um potentially tens of thousands of
people
around the world that are in a sense
uh behind something that are
uh that are either i don't know how
aware
they would have to be about uh whether
or not
this is actually something that is um
at the top of that sort of
hierarchy of of of of
of not knowing that this is actually
what's going on that's a lot of people
and that's that'd be
yeah go ahead yeah go ahead that's a
belief that you have
you believe that there's that many
people working for these agencies
i believe it's a small fraction of that
number and i believe that lots of that
fraction
have no idea because it's all
compartmentalized okay
only the people at the very top of very
few people
will know but i don't believe that
spacex has these thousands of kids
working there
it's not true it's not true i know
dozens of kids that tried to get a job
there that had high academic records and
stuff they all got turned down
not one of them got a job there okay you
know this over the last few years
um nasa you know i don't believe that
there's
nearly that number i think there's a
couple hundred people maybe that worked
there i don't know the exact number
um but they do need people because they
got a fake stuff um
all of the rocket launchers we see are a
deception they're very
they're a trick they're really a trick
um nothing goes to space you know
if you watch a nasa rocket go from
florida
it goes up it curves out over the
bermuda triangle
it's out of sight the smoke trail stops
after just like a minute
and it's gone and no one ever sees it
again and you just see cartoons after
that
okay in arizona
there was a uh a private group of rocket
enthusiasts that made their own rocket
called the go fast rocket
and they had a camera on the side
and a camera god where did all my videos
go i thought i had
i thought i had some of these videos and
they're gone um
had a camera on the side and a camera on
the top
and it shot up and went up 73 miles in
like no time
spinning really fast and also it went
kerplunk into a viscous
liquid okay a viscous medium okay
not as thick as water but it went into
something it stopped spinning
it started floating and it turned on its
side
and you could see the moon go right you
saw the moon okay
well the moon was over australia at that
very moment
okay ball earth arizona
australia is down here okay and it saw
the moon
like it was looking across a flat plain
okay
the horizon is flat
everything we see is above the earth
within the system
the first page of the bible not that i'm
a bible guy but my co-host is
says god separated the waters from the
waters and made the firmament
verna von braun on his gravestone all it
says
is psalm 19 1. and that's about that's
that's the the where it talks about the
firmament god made
you know made separated the waters from
the waters you know if you look at nasa
everything they say is nautical terms
you know
spaceships and everything they talk
about it's all nautical terms
about space and when they want to go to
outer space
i say the outer space is out there it's
out it's out
out there it's out beyond the shoreline
of antarctica
there could be other worlds across the
earth plane
in the outer spaces like here we live
and there's other continents out here
and
some speculate um there's a guy named
martin kenny
who talks about the cosmic egg theory
and he thinks that
mars and venus are a sun and a moon
out here and they circle around
and if you do an experiment with a glass
dome and you have a distant sun
it looks like a star inside our dome
just like we see the wandering star that
we call mars
is amazing stuff again we don't have all
the answers but
when you look there is no curvature
large bodies of water at rest lay flat
okay and we can see too far we can take
their globe math maybe before we move on
because
this is i think it's just helpful for
people to unpack what
the understanding of the flat earth is
is it then
the case that this is the kind of idea
of there being and
this is called like the antarctic basin
and there being some sort of an ice wall
of antarctica
around the entire so yeah if you can
unpack this
yeah so so think of what a pond is a
pond
is a gathering of water at the low spot
of a lan of land right
small puddle you know you go it goes to
the low spot
right a pond is just a big puddle right
and the shoreline of the pond is the
land that's higher than the water
surface right
because if you lowered the end the water
would flow out and go to another low
spot
but if there was some if you had a pond
and there was some big bumps in the pond
that were higher than the water you'd
have some islands
right you with me nod tell me you're
with me
otherwise i think one of the most
fascinating
aspects to this is the fact that there's
no independent exploration allowed
beyond the
yeah that's one of them that's one of
the most fascinating aspects to this
yeah
yeah so so and so check this out what if
you get on a boat and go to england or
go to
australia or just go to the next town
over
you pull up to the shoreline and you
climb out of the boat
and you walk away right when you get to
antarctica
you can't do that because the land is
200 feet over your head
antarctica is the highest land on earth
they don't tell us that in school we
live in the antarctic basin
antarctica is not higher than mount
everest though
there's mountains in antarctica that go
higher than mount everest
right but the the land itself is
higher than any other land on earth
many you know any shorelines the
shoreline of antarctica is higher than
any other shoreline on earth
okay so it's you you hypothesize that
it's this massive
ice wall that is very high not a wall
it's the shore
it's the it's the shore the shore but
it's very high it's very it's not a wall
like the game of thrones where you could
jump off the earth
okay it's not that that that that's all
i see
here it looks like there's a big land
mass is what you say
is is beyond that ice basically i'm just
showing you this is our world
pond we live here this pink line is the
60th parallel
um and there's no exploration beyond
that line you're not allowed to bring
any fuel beyond that line it's still
hundreds of miles from the shoreline
of antarctica so you know you can
what would happen what would happen if i
went to the tip of south america
and then went on an expedition with many
resources down to
antarctica military would stop you and
threaten to sink you
and arrest you which
military in the united nations i mean
they're not standing there holding hands
you know making a circle all the way
around like
people will will hypothesize you know
trying to gaslight you but
there they can see you know the you if
you go
they you will be stopped and again it
takes a lot of resources you need
millions of dollars and if you want to
um if you want to go into penalty
explorer you can file some permits you
can file for a permit it'll cost you a
minimum of 200 000
you will get denied and they will keep
the money there's no returns
okay they make it impossible to explore
but going back to the just the pond here
so this is the pond
and the magnetic north is at the center
and you can go around
as i was talking about before you can
circumnavigate
um i think i was all about it you can
circumnavigate east or west
um around
you that's how you circumnavigate
billions of people have gone
east or west and gone all the way around
to the far east and
come all the way back around and ended
up in new york and they started in
california
right you can go either way but what
nobody
has ever done is gone you know you can
also go
you can also go north and end up on the
other side
but if you go in a straight line and
don't
compensate for your compass you end up
going south
and you hit antarctica no matter where
you go okay
you if you want to go east or west you
have to constantly turn
if you're going west you have to turn to
the right if you want to go east you
have to turn to the left
and you make a circle equidistant from
the center
but if you go south
you just go away and never come back
and you don't pop up on the other side
no one's ever
circumnavigated south isn't that weird
so no one's ever flown an airplane over
antarctica
no you can go over antarctica a little
bit but they turn around so there was a
guy
um i think it's it's called the z pilot
right
and he got the world record for
circumnavigation
he went you know from the north he went
down he came out down to you know the
east coast
went to these islands went over went to
santiago
then he went to antarctica
and then he turned around and came back
and he went all the way up and around
and he got the world record from
guinness for circumnavigation
let me show you what that looks like on
a flat earth map it looks like that
does that look like circumnavigating a
sphere
absolutely not the fact that they won
the world record for the first
circumnavigation
by guinness tells you that there's
deception going on massive deception
okay you know did uh did we look at
flight routes yet we didn't look at
flight routes we haven't done flight
routes yet yeah when you want to
that's an interesting question though
just flying an airplane over antarctica
just going
quote no one's done it going south and
right
yeah if you were if you wanted to go
from santiago chile which is
at the bottom of the ball and australia
is at the bottom of the ball over here
all you gotta do is go across antarctica
right and but they don't
they they don't go they they or or just
stay at like 50 degrees south and go
around the short part of the ball
but they don't do that either when they
want to go to antarctica
they go they go where do they go they go
all they go from it
from santiago chile they go
all the way up to um
here we go they go all the way up to the
united states
they cut across and then they go all the
way back down
so so up across and then down to
australia
that's how they go they show you this
big arch but if you look at that same
path
on a flat earth map it's a straight line
airplanes fly over the earth plane
in straight lines
interesting right
yeah there's a lot that is uh is here
that's
that's that's interesting to think about
for sure yeah
yeah so so let's let's um is that enough
on uh and
art where were we on antarctica um we
could shift gears a little bit
what was what was what is the quote
firmament
in the flat earth yeah the firmament is
the dome is what they call the
as divine as the dome above us
and what is the dome is it energetic
is it glass is it frozen um
i don't know i can't go there it's off
limits you know
is it lay is it far enough away from the
earth where the electric static charge
doesn't pull down and and it has its own
electrostatic charge
that explains what sprites are and and
how lightning works
um it's it's all very interesting but
again
i don't like looking up at the sky
trying to figure out what shape the
floor is you know
look at the lights in your ceiling and
tell me what shape your floor is makes
no sense
you know people say well the moon is a
sphere so the earth is a sphere
are these spheres are these spherical
moons is that a sphere the first one
oh it's a it's cup is the next one a
sphere is this one a sphere before she
touches it
looks like a sphere right is it a sphere
it's not a sphere right is this one a
sphere
what i'm saying is you don't know
what's up in the sky and even if they
are spheres it doesn't matter
you know because you don't know what
you're seeing
do you know what i'm saying so
if the moon is a sphere and it kind of
looks spherical to me if you ask me if
you look at saturn
it really looks spherical but it's not
what they're telling us it's not this
massive body
238 thousand miles away you know it's
its own light
it has phases venus has its phases it's
the same thing as the moon
um saturn is its own light
the rings they they're the same
brightness as the planet and they're
supposed to be
bits of ice floating in space it's crazy
crazy is jupiter's look spherical
does it
does it even look like jupiter because
it's not it's a it's a metal with ducks
in it
[Laughter]
our mind sees what it wants to see
sorry to do that to you but i like that
one
i i was i was checking out why the
planes aren't flying over antarctica
there are
restrictions on aircrafts yeah they can
make up rules all
day long it's too cold it's too
dangerous if they crashed
it's too remote and it would cost too
much to uh
go there you know why don't they fly
from santiago across
you know easter islands in the middle
there there's plenty of places to stop
planes take longer flights over open
ocean
than that but they don't do that either
because you can't because that's not how
the earth is
laid out there's a book called you can
get it for free the ebook
or you can get the coffee table book if
you want to flat smack anybody that
comes to your house
it's called 16 flights 16 emergency
landings
that prove flat earth and it shows
um flight routes where like a flight was
coming from indonesia going to
california with hawaii right in the
middle there
and just halfway to hawaii um a woman
had a baby or someone had a heart attack
or something
and they needed to land so the plane
could have turned around
it could have landed in hawaii it could
have gone to
california but it didn't it went to
alaska
okay that makes zero sense except if you
look at it on a flat earth it's a
straight line and alaska was the next
landmass
okay there's so many of these emergency
landings
where flights go thousands of miles out
of their way
for the emergency landing but then if
you draw the actual route over flat
earth
it makes perfect sense it's the closest
airport
what's going on in the firmament
um what is that then
if it's not a there's astro dynamics
that are occurring with the solar system
orbiting around the black hole in the
center of the milky way
and that when we look up we see all the
other celestial bodies and that the
sun those suns over there are the star
light that we see
what what's going on in that firmament
if it's
uh in the flat earth atlas
we're gonna unpack some stuff today and
you're going to have a lot of stuff to
deal with
because and and by the way i was you
trust me you're going to have to realize
that you've been deceived
on what black holes are who told you
about black holes
the liars that nasa did okay
who told you about all of the stuff that
you just mentioned the liars that nasa
did
okay this is this is unbelievable
i took four years of astronomy in
college i was the man
i was so good at it the girls came with
study with me
they loved me because i knew the stuff
pseudoscience it's all pseudoscience
this is the star arcturus our optics
our consumer optics have outgrown their
lies this is just zooming in
on arcturus okay this
is capella okay it's a little out of
focus but look at these cymatic patterns
i believe that these stars
are sentient in nature okay
we actually had rupert sheldrake on the
show
and he specifically mentioned the
sentience
of stars which i thought it was just an
interesting point to mention along the
way are you are you um
a believer in astrology
oh uh well one of the crazy thoughts
about that is that it's always
interesting hearing kind of the hardcore
uh scientists that
for some reason believe that
like it's possible that the moon
although it uh has the effect that it
does
on the oceans as they say that it
that it that it for some reason would
not have that
effect on the human body which is
composed of approximately
60 or what not water so
are not related to the moon it's
provable it's not related to the moon
you know
we have a big high tide when there's a
full moon i think that's because the
moon is powered up
now when we have a new moon the moon's
not powered up
and we don't have a giant tide but the
moon is still there
it just doesn't have sunlight reflecting
off of it according to the heliocentric
model
the moon's still there why isn't there a
high tide
okay here's the official story here's
the earth
here's the moon and though there's a
high tide right here
because the moon is pulling on those
waters there's also a high tide on the
other side
the official story for that is the moon
is pulling on the waters and it's also
pulling the earth
away from the water on the other side
that's the most the dumbest thing i've
ever heard
okay it's nonsense and the tides don't
correlate with the moons
there's tidal nodes all over the place
okay
i i there's there's uh we have
videos on the app that'll show you about
the title nodes
um how these tides work tides in the
north
are way bigger than tides at the equator
the opposite should be true
because the moon and the sun are in
between the two tropics
so that's where the biggest title so
bulges should be but you know like in
the maldives there's like
less than a foot tide in alaska there's
a 30-foot tide
okay none of that makes any sense
on a on a spinning ball earth none of it
and so then what's the case here with
the optics when you look up at the
firmament what are we what are
we seeing so we're seeing whatever we're
seeing
the only thing that we can honestly say
about any of the things we see in the
sky other than known airplanes
are their lights their luminaries
we don't know how big they are we don't
know how far they are we can't prove it
um and you can only speculate okay this
is uh this is the star um what stars is
this is uh sirius
right this is not what nasa shows us
each of these stars have their own
like personality and they have these
geometric cymatic patterns and
colors it's insane right
um so i love that that's great yeah yeah
but so but then the hypothesis is that
you're saying that
in what in that firmament that you're
saying that
we don't know how actually far away that
that is you can't just
measure the quote light the distance
that the light traveled and then
say that it's that many light years away
there's no such thing as a light year
so the other thing is the um the
how does that work about astrology i
used to laugh at astrology how could you
know
jupiter's conjunction with saturn affect
me it's 25 million miles away it's a
rock in space what difference does it
make or it's gases
how's that gonna affect me well what if
i told you it was within the earth
system
it's a stone's throw away it's energetic
it's uh magnetic it's they're named
after gods
okay maybe stars are souls and the
wandering stars are
are angels gods i don't know
right but they're all of that makes more
sense
you know maybe our our true souls live
you know in the stars and we come and
then we have these experience here maybe
the stars
are the souls i mean without your soul
you you
basically die right but that's the light
you know the energy in our bodies um
i it's all tied together i don't believe
humans can live
off of the earth or far from it i don't
believe anyone's gotten over
i don't know less than two hundred
thousand feet i think
i don't know i mean there was a i when i
was a kid
there were tests doing test pilots you
know where they were
talking about on the news you know when
they're getting ready to go to the or
it was actually before i was a kid but
um they talked about these test clock
pilots
they were flying you know these planes
super high and they were saying that
they pass out
they could see through their eyelids
they they they couldn't
think you know because they're too far
away from this electric earth
we're part of the earth system right we
can't be
away from it in my opinion
this this is this matrix reality that
we're in
it's it's wild
and then you also mentioned that
the uh
maybe this would be a good one to sort
of go to next
i think you were mentioning it but we
didn't really get to talk about we
actually talked about this a little bit
with uh joshua erp on the show
who ended up unpacking some of his
thoughts around this space as well and
then that's how i believe
somebody that was watching the interview
introduced us
and then recommended that we have you on
the show
and that one of the things that joshua
was mentioning that it looks like
we can maybe talk to you about as well a
little bit here is that sort of idea
of that what we what we've what we've
become familiar with as a curvature
but in this case it is a very sort of
flat
and you kind of had that image up
earlier where there was that flat
with you had a star that was sort of
orbiting it on
up from the top maybe you can yeah bring
that back
and sort of explain um yeah so explain
kind of how the
those those quote astro dynamics would
work
in the flat earth so the what you're
seeing there is the sun on the moon
um circling around there's a full moon
because it's diametrically opposed
to um to the earth let me let me show
you
well so the question is how does that
sun
and moon float in the sky how does it i
don't believe the sun and the moon that
we see
are physical here's a little experiment
i did this is a glass dome on top of a
white rug a fluffy rug
and i'm moving a pen light across level
with the ground
across and you watch inside the dome
you'll see this little sun
and it goes down now it's going to come
back in a second and it never goes below
the bottom
it just stops right there and it just
fades away
as the light goes away so here comes the
light again
and it's hard to see on the video but
it's inside there's a there's
like a sphere inside there and then it
goes away watch
it'll stop right at the bottom and then
it fades away
to nothing okay here here's the the same
thing
um this is a little flat earth model and
there's a sun floating in the middle in
there
what is that right well the real sun
is above the firmament and i'm just
holding a light above the firmament and
spinning it around
and we're seeing this crazy thing in the
sky
so so flat earth is layered where you
have
a firmament that's above the
flat earth and then you have a you have
the celestial like the sun
is above the firmament israel don't know
within the firmament it could be above
the firmament it could be projected from
the north pole
like like the planetarium projects
everything from the north from the
center
okay it could be but we don't have
access
to there either so um let me show you a
a real world example of what i'm
what i'm talking about so
this is the sun i have my drone it's a
super
super clear day this is super zoomed in
so it's a little fuzzy
and i watched the sun go from here way
up way up here
it took five minutes it went down down
down down down and then it stopped right
at this horizon
and it sat there for 10 minutes now
this is sped up like 2500 percent watch
it doesn't go
down it's stopped which proves the earth
isn't spinning
and then it just watch it doesn't go
below it just
fades into the thickness i'm going to
zoom out a little bit you can see it
again
it sat there for 10 minutes and then it
just
faded out this is a super clear
zero humidity day it was cold um
no humidity crystal clear and it just
fades away
now the sun's still there but it just
can't
push through the thickness of the
atmosphere
i call it the atmospheric density
and this line right here that that
horizon
that we see is not the ground that's
just the atmospheric density level
that becomes opaque and it looks like
it's the ground just due to perspective
if you see clouds above your head you
know they've spotted pop fluffy fluffy
clouds at
five ten thousand feet whatever they are
25 miles away over the water
they're touching the water they
literally become
the same horizon and you can't tell the
difference so if i have a sun
up you know here here's this atmospheric
deck of opacity
above your eye level and i've got a sun
and the sun just goes away
it's not going down but it looks like
it's setting
and this line here looks like it's the
horizon
so literally you know if i do it here
watch you're gonna it's not gonna set
because it's not above your eye level
but when it's above your eye level it
sets
it's all due to atmosphere now in the in
the app
let me let me show you real quick in the
app how the two minute run through
of the flat earth model you okay with
that yeah let's see it in the app
yeah so yeah you're you're not only the
founder and host of the flat earth
podcast but also the creator of the flat
earth
sun moon and zodiac clock app so this is
what we're looking at it's on
is this on ios and android both it is it
is i'll give you a link to put in the
description
um so this is the flatter sun moon and
zodiac clock app
um and so remember we live in the
antarctic base and i'm going to go into
settings here and let me just
put a more descriptive background these
are just decorative backgrounds
so there there's antarctica right
whatever i
i like i like that one it's actually not
antarctica but it's
it is what it is so there's the the
world pond
right here and the sky is a perfect
clock it's not a beehive that doesn't
work
it's a perfect clock so the sun goes
around once every 24 hours
okay and it laps the moon and once
i'll speed it up it laps the moon once
every 28 days so you'll see after a
couple more times around
um it laps the moon and
the moon will be full when it's opposed
to the sun at 180 degrees
now if you look at where the sun is
right now it's over that outer yellow
line
and that's the tropic of capricorn i'll
slow it down so you don't get dizzy
all right it's over the topic of
capricorn it's actually
exactly over the topic of capricorn
today because we're at the winter
solstice december 21st
six months later it'll migrate inwards
to the tropic of cancer so in june it's
now
june 22nd it's over the tropic of cancer
now we live in the inner northern
lands we live in the inner northern land
so in june
it's our summer and the outer the outer
lands
the outer southern lands have their
winter mm-hmm yeah
yeah i see how you're modeling this yeah
i see how you're modeling this
all right so this is how it works and
i'm gonna i'm gonna prove to you that
i'm right
okay so right now it's december 21st
it's the middle of our winter
and it's the height of the of
australia's summer it's brutally hot in
australia because the sun is right over
them
right so the sun wherever the sun is
it's 12 noon ready it's 12
noon now in western australia okay
and so wherever the sun is on this it's
it's 12
noon so if i turn on the stars
these are all the zodiacal stars and
right now we're in between
two uh two um zodiac signs
and the zodiac spins slightly faster
than the sun that it'll it takes a full
year for the zodiac to lap the sun
so the sun is going to move into what is
this what are we going to the tourists
whatever um and then the next month
it'll move over to the next one the next
month it'll be in pisces
right because this will take a full year
it spins with the sun but it's going
slightly faster
and that's how the sun is in um in
its sign for 12 for uh for a month you
know all 12 signs
the moon itself will move in and out of
signs every couple of days
so it'll show you where the moon is also
um let me turn off turn that off
and i'll turn on the world time
so this is how time zones work right now
it's like 10 30 in the morning in
eastern australia
okay it's noon in new zealand you can't
see new zealand but it's right under the
sun
right it's um 7 30
in the east coast right here okay so
this
this ring here spins with the sun
and that tells you what time it is in
all of those lands
all right i'll turn that off um
and the um
what else i'm going to show you on here
oh yeah so so the question is
you'll say well what about and you hit
the question mark
and you say you know um what about
circumnavigation i think we talked about
that
you know what what about seasons we
which i just showed you how seasons work
you know
what about southern flights we talked
about that you know or why the lie
and if you click any one of these up
comes what google will never give you
these are the videos that will tell you
all about it
like if you search flat earth you're
going to get the flatter society
you're going to get a bunch of junk if
you search hey flatter anything that's
flat earth in it
new every day they load they load
hundreds of new
crap videos to gatekeep you to make you
go oh this is stupid
there's nonsense there's fighting it's
just
it's just garbage so all of your
questions are answered here
this is uh the web page we have stuff on
mud floods and
um all sorts of stuff but what's going
to happen is
when you google flat earth you're going
to get nat geo saying oh then we went to
the sultan c and they did an experiment
there and we proved curvature
no they didn't they they lied and we
basically in the middle one down here
debunking the debunkers
all of those hit pieces done by them
we don't just take them and go they're
lying we show you how they're
faking it clearly not even a question we
show you that national geographic is
lying
that you know the omni is lying that
that
uh they're they're lying about all of
the stuff so if you catch them lying
something's wrong we have different
languages playlists
in different languages um and
there's just a whole bunch of other
things the app does it's got it it takes
you to dark sky if you click the weather
um but here's what i tell people if you
think flat earth is
stupid if you think nasa is in any way
real okay take the daily app challenge
the daily featured video app challenge
every day a new video will show up here
you click it
and it brings you to the daily video
short ones during the week longer ones
on the weekend
um and just watch it every day for two
weeks one video a day for two weeks
right it doesn't take much time but
you're having breakfast whatever
and guaranteed by the end of that two
weeks
you will know a lot more than you know
now and here's what happens
people say hey hi dave i saw you on
atlas's show
you really pissed me off and i bought
your stupid app for 2.99
to have a beer and i didn't want to wait
every day
so i click the archive button and what
that does is it brings you to
all of the videos listed by month for
the last couple years and
they go i haven't slept in two days i
don't know what to do with myself
you know there's something wrong with
the globe what do i do and i'm like
welcome to flat earth
um if we hit the compass button this is
how a compass works on flat earth as i
was telling you
if you go east if you go west from here
you go
west is 270 degrees dead reckoning
brings you all the way around and back
east brings you all the way around the
back going north
from the united states north north north
north north south south now i'm going
south
right and i'm going in a straight line
none of those three things
proves that the earth is a globe or flat
because you can do them on both
what proves that the earth is not a
globe
is nobody goes from south america
and pops up in australia or you know
from
from uh johannesburg and pops up in new
zealand nobody does it
nobody does it if the earth was a globe
it'd be done
all the time right that would that's
probably one of my favorite
experiments from our conversation that i
would love
for us to conduct um a couple years ago
they said they're you can be the first
we're going to book a fl a flight across
uh antarctica it's going to go to
australia from santiago
and they sold tickets people paid like
ten thousand dollars a ticket
and it was going to be a historic thing
and they built it up they built it up
they built it up they got everyone's
money
and then it disappeared and they never
did it
so that yeah this is this would be
probably my one of my favorite
like interesting and also simple it's
not that difficult in the sense of just
bringing the videography equipment and
then going on
um a flight uh and then just capturing
the entirety of the process
and that's probably one of the easiest
ways
to leverage that sort of scientific
methodological process
to um validate said um
uh concepts about the world that we live
in i think that's a
that's a really that's a really kind of
like first principled one is take the
flight for uh
of fly from uh south africa or from
south america and uh go over antarctica
and um that's a that's a good one i like
that one a lot
atlas i like it too no one's ever done
it no one will ever do it the earth is
flat
it's a moot point it's a great argument
we should do it
we should do it you can't do it they
won't allow you to do it people have
tried
well we should we should yeah it would
be great because
then we would know we would also go to
the moon why don't we just go to the
moon
we apparently are again which is
fantastic
and that's when in 2025 how far did they
kick it down the road this time
something like that it's it's apparently
it's a very difficult
project you know we're just uh one
percent genetically different than our
fellow chimpanzees so it's how come
they're still chimpanzees how come they
didn't evolve
how what during our lives how what
animal has turned into another animal
okay well humans are i mean humans are
what like a hundred thousand
modern you know years old so we are we
five thousand years old
or we last here's the thing you can't
prove
anything before the 1900s it's all
all of our history is um is
is uh is a lie you know the the
transcontinental railroads weren't built
they were excavated okay
they were excavated they were here
before this round of civilization
okay there was an advanced civilization
on the app
under the web button bottom right corner
mud floods tataria
bring food and water if you click that
button because you're not coming out for
a long time
okay bring food and water
here's the thing my friend there's so
much
that you you're gonna have to realize
that
anything you hear from nasa anytime you
hear
anything from nasa anything with the
with the country north korea in it
or anything with the word nuclear bombs
in it you have to discount it 100 oh
yeah
thank you for bringing this back up so
then what is
your perspective about both the
uh nuclear bombs and also nagasaki
and and north korea and also yeah i mean
we talk
in modernity we use the number that
there's approximately
over 10 000 nuclear bombs that are
mostly owned by the united states and
russia
who told you that the guys on the news
the government the guys that are here
for our health
the guys that don't want to control us
they don't want us to be in
fear do they the whole
nuclear bombs do not exist so let's talk
about hiroshima nagasaki real quick
so that there's this no such thing as a
nuclear bomb
period so this is now so what happens
what about 1945 what
what was your perspective about the 1945
droppings of the
nuclear weapons in hiroshima and
nagasaki
yeah okay so
after those bombs went off no reporters
were allowed to report what's going on
there only one reporter that was a
government
controlled reporter was allowed to
report anyone else
taking pictures or reporting was jails
okay so that's interesting did you know
that after those bombs went off
three days later the trains were running
the flower shops were selling flowers on
the street the stores were open
and people went back to work three days
after those bombs went off
okay there's video of them stock
piling up pallets and pallets and
pallets of tnt
at ground zero prior to the explosion
okay nuclear bombs
don't exist period they don't exist
there's no such thing as a nuclear bomb
it's all just to build up the the war
machine
keep us in fear because if you are lost
in space
living in fear of asteroids and nuclear
bombs
you are powerless and you give your
power away willingly
you lose control of your life and that's
what they want
this is a spiritual war they want
control of your soul
and they're going to scare the [ __ ] out
of you to give it up
okay north korea
kim jong-un is not the leader of north
korea north korea
is nothing like they tell us kim jong-un
is a mental patient
from an institution who can can barely
talk they get him to clap in front of a
green screen
and it's him and and they show you all
of these
troops and missiles and you zoom in on
those high-resolution pictures of the
troops
they're the same troops stepped and
repeated again and again and again it's
all fake there are no rockets that go
into space there are no intercontinental
ballistic missiles there is there are
like
cruise missiles that's cool it goes i
don't know a couple hundred miles maybe
but that's it a lot to unpack
i don't want you to so here's the thing
if you want to learn about nuclear bombs
there's one show that you have to watch
crow triple seven radio crow with two
r's
crow triple seven radio go to his
website
pro triple seven radio dot com with two
hours and look up
the nuclear bomb hoax video um
there's their two hour shows hour one is
free you don't have to pay for it
um and that's just just listen to that
first hour
and you will know that there's no such
thing as nuclear bombs
you also know that north korea doesn't
exist
oh that it just doesn't exist it's there
but it's not the country that they're
telling you it's probably where the
elite go
and you know have who knows what they're
doing over there
it's a land that we have no access to
you have no you don't see anything
any you remember when dennis rodman went
there it was a bunch of guys in front of
computers that didn't even know what
they were doing
okay they didn't show anything go find
footage of
kim jong-un doing anything intelligent
that proves that he's anything
above a fifth grade mental patient
okay there's nothing right and he's the
guy that's
you know keeping the world at bay it's
just to scare
us yeah all of what you were saying
about
fear is extremely important we kind of
talked about that metaphysically
throughout the program that in a sense
the creation
is a perfect harmonic flux between
two poles as they sort of ascend
in a process of of evolution and
unfoldment and
it's sort of that's one of the greatest
symbols that's ever been made which is
the yin and yang and then if you sort of
add in that that electromagnetism like a
helical coil
and you add a strange attractor at the
top which is like a god head which is
what we're evolving towards as a complex
system
that what you've identified repeatedly
is sort of the
that darkness which keeps people in fear
and in many ways that is what people
even ones that are potentially not
associated with flat earth
they very clearly know many of them that
there are there there
is some sort of a deeper fear
propaganda structure that exists that
keeps people asleep
to their full awakening and their full
actualized potential and
their full ability to
to build an architect a more abundant
and prosperous future for absolutely
everybody that
doesn't have some sort of a short term
gratification fulfilling self-dealing
ego driven processes but rather ones
that are
very deeply light love wisdom
based inclusive stakeholding shared
equity for people around the planet and
so
that's uh definitely something that we
talk about on the program
a lot and sort of helping people realize
that we are the ones that must be the
those light architects and go in that
direction away from
that fear and so it's interesting to
hear your thoughts about nuclear weapons
and north korea
as well in this process all about fear
there's nothing to fear
so you know yep
you have to give up a lot um it seems
like you're giving up a lot
when you accept the facts that we're on
a flat stationary plane
like all of we've been programmed our
whole lives from before
we can talk with ball and you know
sesame street and all the kids
programming it's all
ball programming verna von braun and
nasa astronauts are on sesame street
they're you go to school you got a globe
rockefeller funny globe at the front of
every class
you know global news universal pictures
with their spinning globe
everything is
just programming and then all of the
movies star wars star trek you know
battlestar galactica who the level
everyone loves space
so you're you're caught in the air and
then aliens well there's got to be
aliens you know that's the big debate
well i believe there's extraterrestrials
they come from the extra terror
beyond antarctica the extra land
territory
extraterrestrials okay
they don't travel trillions of miles
and then come here and crash in roswell
they're coming from beyond antarctica
okay um and that's it i mean or they'd
be coming from lands
out in the southern oceans that we can't
get to because gps makes you go this way
and gps makes you go that way and east
and west there's
circles so you there's swaths of ocean
that nobody ever goes in
remember that this is going to be the
best i think project to do
is sort of fund a
an avid a very well documented
uh video of
a crew um that is non-biased
uh to go on this expedition over
uh antarctica in a flight and
that would be a very important piece of
content
in the sense of whether it be supporting
either one of these or debunking either
one of these you can do it
you would wipe out the flat earth
movement it would be over
god bless you but you can't do it
because it doesn't exist
that's very fascinating that we got to
this point on the conversation though
one of one of the heads of the flat
earth
movement david weiss says
that if we can scientifically
non-biased probably provably
undergo this process maybe we even put
david
in the actual flight along with
scientists and people that are
non-biased
you know this type of thing they tried
to do that they had it and that they
they had a flight plan then they started
putting restrictions on
no scientific equipment is allowed on
the airplane
right and then people you know a bunch
of flat earthers
actually a few flat earthers paid for
the trip they were going to go on and
and they were going to bring you know
compasses and all sorts of you know
and other gyros and stuff
they stole all the money they canceled
the flight they're like there's no way
we're gonna do this
right that flight was to prove that they
were gonna fake it
and make people believe that it was done
but when flat earthers infiltrated it
they cancelled the whole thing here's a
simpler one that uh
that you could try to do but it would
never work is
antarctica is an island you know a
continent at the bottom of the ball
you get two ships that can see the
shoreline of antarctica
and they go in opposite directions one
goes to the right
one goes to the left always keeping the
shoreline in view
and 7 000 miles later they should meet
they won't because it's like 60 000
miles around
right remember the equator is only 24
000 miles
that's another interesting experiment so
now there's two
uh that's another interesting one so if
they both so if you start
both of these two ships larger ships
let's say we bring these similar crews
on board each of them um
yes keep antarctica in sight as both
ships
go the opposite direction and
technically
they should meet here on 1000 miles
later
yeah yeah yeah and that's i love these
two experiments i'm telling you this is
this is what this
uh i'm telling you this is the whole
point
of our show simulation the entire point
of our show
is to do exactly what you and i just got
to
so it require it requires
uh people to not be dogmatic first of
all it requires people to not be
fundamentalist
because in this case i have
a level of in this case is called a
mirror consciousness
as an interviewer and so i'm willing
to undergo a high emotional intelligence
process
of going through an hour of dialectic
with you in a loving and compassionate
way to unfold sort of what your world
view is
and then what we get to is a very
fascinating
scientifically methodologically
process that we can undergo two there's
two
options to undergo here let's do both
which would be even better to do both of
these that would then
provide our our world
with another uh augmented
understanding of what is the true
nature of our existence and so i think
this is extremely beautiful and
important and i'm really glad that we
got here together and this is going to
be something that
i now passionately embark on as one of
the many
projects that's in our in our
trains that are that are rolling that
we're putting fuel into because
to get the planet to want to fund these
two ways of understanding the nature
of of our existence and like you said
david weiss even said it here on the
show
he said that if those two projects go
through
and that they prove uh what
the models that exist today say is true
then the whole flat earth society would
be wiped out
which is very interesting that he said
that yeah we're not the vladimir society
but yes they'd be
what do you what do you what do you call
it's just the flat earth researchers
yeah
it's controlled definition control okay
okay
sorry so they'd be wiped out too
yeah yeah yeah there you go so it's just
flat earth researchers there you go
and i was i was looking up the numbers
as well in terms of
if some of these numbers are true in
terms of
having somewhere around maybe
maybe 10 of people in the united states
that think that um the spherical earth
model is maybe there's 10 million people
in the us that don't
think the spherical earth model is
correct or maybe there's potentially
even
a hundred million people around the
planet that don't believe the spherical
earth model is correct
and so what we could do is by running
these experiments
we can actually have a significant
amount of people around the planet
potentially um undergo a process of wow
now that i've seen these two experiments
and maybe we even
create a par a process of people like
like you were saying a rollercoaster
ride in a sense
for people to go on these flights or on
these ships
to be able to see it themselves that way
it's no longer
so we can actually make the proper
businesses
around this to even make these things
sustainable and i think that's really
interesting and important from the heart
to do this type of stuff
all right atlas i think we got to wrap
it up i got another interview in five
minutes
oh oh [ __ ] okay yeah beautiful wow what
a cool ending david yeah this is so
interesting i really appreciate you a
lot all right and
you got a lot of thinking to do because
when you unpack this stuff
sometimes you gotta people say it
doesn't matter what we show you flat
earthers you're never willing to change
your mind well guess what
we changed our mind we believed in the
globe our entire lives
and we were able to put that away i will
change my mind
based on new good information okay show
me the good information i've been doing
it for six years
i've been asking people show me one
proof one reason that you believe you
live on a globe and the only thing i get
is
that i was taught in school you know
pictures in the i saw it on tv
you know that's not a proof one proof of
the globe
nobody can come up with one and then
people i go
don't you think that's weird that you
can't come up with one
they're like well i still believe the
earth is a globe
right and i'm like
yeah this this comes up with one anyway
wait here's just
telling people come up with one
get my app it's the question mark that's
what we did your answer
the question is answered in there
guarantee this is this is what we did at
the end of the show is we got
to a process that would enable people to
experientially not even based on
information that they read online but
experientially undergo either that ship
or that flight process
that would then experientially anchor
that style of thought process within
them
okay let's wrap so thank you everybody
for tuning in we greatly appreciate you
um what an interesting uh episode that
we had with dave thank you for coming on
the program
thanks for tuning in everyone let us
know your thoughts in the comments below
on the episode we would love to hear
from you about some of the things that
we were learning
and also if like the video let's get
this video some more reach
subscribe if you haven't to the channel
also share the video with more people
so that more people can learn about this
and also the solutions that we're
proposing which is super
interesting and support
you can support davey and support us our
links are all in the bio below
support us help us flourish manifest our
goals and manifest your own dreams
into the world as well and the other
scientists entrepreneurs
engineers spiritual leaders artists in
your communities
help them flourish as well we love you
very much thank you for tuning in
we will see you soon everyone much love
peace